everyone always thinks that the Grass Is
Always Greener they think if they go to
another country they'll get a better
life but that's not always the case
because every country has its own unique
specific ways of keeping you enslaved in
the system take the US for example so
you know how the US keeps you enslaved
through the food the food is literally
made up of plastic and sugar and then
you get sick and then how do they solve
that well then they sell you pills and
then the pills they make you sick and
then it's like this continuous cycle of
of pills and the whole thing just keeps
you ill and sick in the UK it's all
about poor people mentality keeping you
poor it's all about you'll do anything
for a quiet life Don't Rock the Boat
don't be too loud don't be too
entrepreneurial don't be too
business-minded and that mentality keeps
you poor the Middle Eastern Asia is all
about religion it's about giving your
life up for religion fighting a holy war
staying in a war zone because God told
you to stay there rather than leaving
and fleeing and actually building a
better life for yourself